ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan shut where's your mask you don't
have a mask you want me go get one
hey are you are you violating the
Beverly Hills law that if you come in
with six feet of another person you have
to wear a mask everybody looks like the
[ __ ] Phantom of the Opera here this
is my reusable cloth mask which is these
are disgusting I mean you don't want to
reuse a mask you want to throw it out
when you breathe in it yeah it's really
I mean this is atrocious you know and I
had a I had an eggplant parmesan today
that was truly life-changing and I I'm
not getting money from these people or
anything I just want to say a shout out
to dominicos specialty store you know an
Italian specialty store that Sal Vulcano
on the a'practice Jokers
turned me on to and Pulver's e among
others great eggplant parm is such a
tough dish to make cuz it's either too
mushy like where it's literally or the
eggplant slices are cut too thick but
this was perfect like it was absolutely
perfect
and it comes frozen and you heat it up
in the oven or the microwave every time
there's a choice between the oven and
the microwave I just do microwave
because I did cocaine at 13 and when you
do cocaine at 13 you've grown up in a
home where you use the microwave a lot
so I'm no stranger to the microwave I
don't care that it radiates your food
and it radiates you and I mean the only
reason I'm not dying of coronavirus
might be the fact that I stand in front
of the microwave and stare it in while
the little food goes around remember
when microwavable food was considered
like a healthy option yeah like people
would go and get literally a chunk of
frozen something that look like an
artifact that was foul
and then it would melt and then become
something like they had Lean Cuisine had
sandwiches for a while where you would
literally like he was like add water and
then it would become a [ __ ] sandwich
and they had these you know they would
serve them in these little trays yeah
there they are
they served them in these little trays
crisping sleeves click crisping trays
and he would crisp up this and when you
were eating a Lean Cuisine sandwich and
that's what it really looks like right
down there that's what it really looks
like when you're eating that and I've
eaten that you're in an office and
you're eating a Lean Cuisine sandwich
like that and and then you got to put
that up on the podcast because when
you're eating something like that man
there is no reason that you don't take
out a I mean whatever gun would blow
your head clear off 45 I'm something
where there wouldn't even be a chance
you'd live like it would have to just
take you out but I've seen it man I've
done it I've seen secretaries fat people
that are trying to get ahead trying to
get ahead of you know just choke down a
Lean Cuisine microwavable sandwich I
mean the horrors of mass-produced
diet food because before people before
there was this organic movement or
farm-to-table there were people that
were like the same what I love about
like this era of dieting they were like
the same people who [ __ ] us are gonna
help us now right like the same
companies that have done nothing but
push sludge down our throats through
drive-through windows are now going to
answer the call and provide us with
healthy alternatives that we just add
water and it's a steak just add water
and I watched my mother and countless
fat Long Island women go and then men as
well more shamefully
a man a man pulling out a Lean Cuisine
then there was like an element where it
almost got weirdly masculine like if you
had a Lean Cuisine in the break room you
had to kind of be you had to peacock a
little and be a dick like go [ __ ] alig
was it sort of [ __ ] what like if people
be like relax dude calm down you know
but that's that's what health food was
for a very long time was just genuine I
mean look at look at that I mean could
you imagine sitting now you don't really
see now I guess I haven't been in an
office environment in a long time but
I'm sure there are still people out
there choking down a Lean Cuisine
they're tough there's a little Asian
chicken one which is just four to five
morsels of the meat that the FDA his
rule is close enough to chicken and then
just like a a little like a handful of
angel hair pasta and it recycles it gets
so hot that when you when there's no
Lean Cuisine that you put in your mouth
well you don't burn your mouth
third-degree burn maybe that was the
strategy could all these people just
burn their mouths and they won't eat
right because these linked cuisines get
hotter than anything I've ever seen in
my life
I mean they get hotter than a cast-iron
pan because there it's just chemicals
have you ever lit plastic on fire that's
what this is that's what these things
are it's amazing to watch but an amazing
eggplant parmesan today from dominicos
Thank You dominicos let's do the death
counts where are we everybody
coronavirus cases right now in the world
two million eight hundred thirty one
thousand seven hundred and eighty four
depths 197 306 recovered eight hundred
and six thousand nine hundred and fifty
three let's do it by country we're about
to break a million in the USA tell them
what they've won they've won a Great
Depression young people are having
strokes no one knows why nobody knows
you go to the hospital you may not live
this is a it's a brutal sickness man
even though I criticize like the way the
government's handled it and we can all
debate what's coming and everything like
that it is a real virus like the people
out there to think that this is not real
or mentally ill like it's people are
getting it and they're dying I don't
listen you may say you might look at the
numbers and go huh
those are worried me but that's fine and
you can make a judgment on the mortality
rate but like there are people in
hospitals right now checking out in
their 40s in their 30s and it's you know
you know in the USA there's some real
critical there's 15,000 critical cases
in the USA that doesn't seem like a lot
and it's not a lot but I also could be
the result of the fact that nobody's
been outside because once everybody
starts going outside you might see more
cases if China did this and they
introduced a vaccine and then we all
take the vaccine and then they flip on
the 5g switch and we all explode or we
all fall to the ground and start shaking
you got to give it to China you've got
folks folks you got to give it to them
credit where credit is due
sometimes you gotta know when you've
been beat they're gonna win Maputo in in
in in while they're still screamin in in
in in a crematorium and then put them in
a
they're gonna win here we're apologizing
because we said the wrong word they're
gonna win it's just a matter of when
and if they really did this and then the
five G starts being used and people just
fall to the ground and start shaking I
mean hats off to China I don't I don't
want to I don't want it to be the case
but if that is the case as so many of
you happen to believe then hey what are
you gonna do what are you really gonna
do all these people are going to work
Trump doesn't care about these people
yeah he doesn't he does it he's not
gonna Obama didn't I understand it's
shitty to work at a meat processing
plant
when this pandemic is happening how fun
was it pre-pandemic to work at the meat
packing plant
what kind of barrel of fun was it
packaging meat before this for no money
let me know maybe I'm wrong maybe it was
a real ball
everyone who's having at the meat
packaging plant before corona I could be
wrong meat needs to be packaged people
need to package meat I like me so do you
if we fire all the P they this comes
down to the fact that not everybody is
going to there are people out there that
work at jobs that are not there's no
silver lining so their silver lining is
a ciggy or a glass of booze or maybe a
nice pill or the Lord Jesus or you know
dark web torture porn or a nice big
Buford to checkers nice sloppy Buford
but the job's not
getting better at the meat plant it's
think about it think about working it to
meet plan it's not nice it's not good
everyone's like bow workers that the
meat by the way did anyone give a [ __ ]
about any of these essential workers
before they're essential they're making
$8 an hour they're essential
we've never treated them like essential
workers and I'm saying that's [ __ ] up
I'm saying that's not good but we've
never treated them like I said because
let's be on it if you're essential in a
pandemic it doesn't mean you're
essential without a pandemic and I'm I
respect the [ __ ] out of the grocery
clerks that are out there but it's it's
you know it's a different world now and
you're now essential but you weren't
essential and it's insulting you to
pretend that we think you're really we
don't think you're really essential I
gotta be honest with you I'm telling the
truth
Susan Sarandon well maybe she will Saran
is all over the place and probably on
pills and might say things it makes
sense occasionally but you know what I
mean the the the the the people out here
in Hollywood and their pools they're not
gonna tell you the truth I'm telling you
the truth we don't really think you're
essential we just don't want you to die
I don't want to die and I don't want you
to die but we don't think you're
essential and we gone if any of us and I
mean anybody had to work it to
meatpacking plant they would blow their
head off I'm just saying I'm not
insulting you at the plant I have to be
honest if you don't expect honesty from
me I don't know what I can give you
truly if you're not expecting honesty
here so let's cut the [ __ ] and this
canard about the essential work it's
it's grillak all of these celebrities
like it's the thank you bus drivers [ __ ]
one hey [ __ ] one [ __ ] bus driver make
them essential to your [ __ ] [ __ ] one of
these people that you say are essential
take them home
open your beautifully manicured snatch
to someone packing meat at the plant how
about that put your money where your
mouth is and put his mouth where your
mouth is or her mouth go grab a big
feisty Dyke at the Tyson chicken plant
and let her go down on you why not cuz
you're essential thank you
is there anything now I brought food
twice to the nurses and the doctors in
it and I immediately regretted it and I
paid once
Whitney paid the other time she's done
well uh and and the reality is this I
want I want the nurses in it but then I
realized they don't need food they don't
need me showing up with with baked ziti
you don't need me showing up with trays
of lasagna this isn't a retirement party
in a VFW hall in Long Island City er
they need other [ __ ] PPE vaccine listen
I'm all for helping people but I have to
be honest now because if we're not
honest we're gonna we're going to we're
going to devolve rapidly into a world
where people are always lying at every
man and that's gonna get us all killed
sooner or later if we're not honest we
have to be honest you don't care about
the essential workers you can't flip a
switch and start caring about someone
overnight you truly do not care because
here's the thing some of these essential
work and I understand but some of them
still have attitudes I'll rip the mask
off your face
do you understand I said where's the
gravlax the gravlax is different than
the regular smoked-salmon [ __ ] you know
this you know this the smoked salmon
and the bread the gravlax is cured with
the dill don't treat me I will I'll grab
the mask off your face is what I'm okay
let's cut the [ __ ] I know that
everybody's treating you like you're
just you know so let's cut it out I am
all for paying these people more [ __ ]
money but I'm not for these fake social
media displays of affection too strange
eh don't care stop banging pots and pan
yes it is nice for a little while it is
nice I understand that but do we need
deeper structural change you know i know
david dobrik is going around la shooting
a t-shirt candidate people and they're
making $10,000 that's lovely but perhaps
there needs to be a more widespread
effort at healing the wealth divide
that's so entertaining because we live
in a fallen world where you're you know
people's only hope now is that the
billionaire from YouTube shoots a
t-shirt cannon at them with $10,000 I
was I thought he was just going around
la shooting people which I supported and
I said now now I get it
I get it I people I was like why is this
guy so popular he's a cutie and he's
nice and I do like I do like about dopey
flip but you know I was always said
likewise he said and then I looked they
go oh he's just running around and he's
shooting people and I go what I like and
I think there's something about that
he's embracing where we are and what
needs to be done they were going he's
going around and he's shooting families
in need and at that point I said well I
like that right he sees a family in need
he goes well they're a [ __ ] I don't
need for leeches get him out of here I
was like I'm in for that
now put suppose he's giving the money I
don't like that I don't like that but
he's going around to families in me this
is American 2020 I want everybody to
take a deep breath and runs where
America is in 2020 Americans wonder if
you are a family in
in America you can only rely on the
YouTube guy shooting you with a t-shirt
cannon and hope to god it has a check in
it because the government is not-- we're
no longer a functional state that's
where we are that's not a joke that's
not a bit that's not a bit and and the
government will provide you nothing your
only hope is that you happen to be
walking around the same area as the
YouTube millionaire who's shooting ten
thousand dollar checks at you that's
charity in America he's gonna shoot a
potato gun and he's gonna bury a ten
thousand dollar check in a potato and
then shoot it at you that's that is
America right now and you trended on
Twitter for it I feel like he's the best
person that's ever lived and I have no
I'm not saying don't do charity but I'm
saying that's where we are I have to
step not everything could be about
selling sneakers which is my problem
about existing in the digital world
because that's literally everything here
is just about and we are launching a
line of something soon and I don't want
don't come at me and say well what about
this and either that you go [ __ ] your
mother is what that is because we're
launching something very soon it's gonna
be very good for everybody and and all
of the donations will go to Hollywood
celebrities who are already wealthy
because we're not throwing good money
after bad I'm telling you that families
in need why are you a family away from
me grows go get David go chase david
dobrik down the street maybe he'll shoot
you with it with it with her with a
t-shirt at him maybe there'll be a wet
t-shirt contest which at the end of it
david dobrik he gives you 30 grand in
pennies and you have to crawl around the
street and and stuff them in your ass it
doesn't matter but that's where we are
as a country and be happy be happy David
I'm not I'm not insulting him be happy
he's there I'm out of the money to do
that I don't know if the sponsors that
help me do that either okay I guess I
could fling Ridge wallets at these
families in need which by the way I saw
the videos you know how I need these
people were
people that are in need you can't shoot
something out in many cases because they
would shoot you back I wish he shot
something with ten grand I would I was
so yelling at him like what the [ __ ] am
I gonna do with ten grand in LA go to
lunch go to lunch but that's where we're
at the government gave you $1,200 david
dobrik giving you ten thousand that's
something to think about that's
something to think about the fact that
you have to rely on a video from a
youtuber like you look if you're a poor
person or you're somebody in need
you have to retweet Jeffrey star and
hope that he gives you money that's part
of the American system now part of the
American system is YouTube philanthropy
that's part of America now people do it
they tweet at these people I am my loans
are their student loans I can my dad is
sick it's it's terrifying and tragic and
it's part of America now that YouTube
philanthropy is the thing you just gotta
wait for whatever narcissist on YouTube
is willing to throw your money I want to
go around with a gun and take ten
thousand dollars from people and I would
love that if that was the video if you
tubers got together and went around
Beverly Hills and took ten grand from
people with a gun not a t-shirt gun a
real got a big-boy gun took ten grand
from people I would watch that video
under saying this is where we are people
say I don't have anything on the pad
circle represents a circle of life I
like having the pad here [ __ ] off please
join the patreon there's there's
hundreds of thousands of you listening
to this we have 4,500 page what are you
gonna do it's all over they're not
making any more movies this year they're
not make in a year you're gonna have to
wait for owes and sees our Ozarks season
four okay which will be written by AI at
that point and you'll all love it so
don't you know get excited over there
Ozark everybody it's the best show it's
it's great Laura Linney and Jason
Bateman are phenom and Julia Garner are
amazing actors and they do a great job
with what I would consider is an OK
script it is fine it is a serviceable
piece of work for those great actors to
do every movie or TV show right now
should just be me yelling at people
there is no reason to have any other
entertainment right now it is tone-deaf
it is tone-deaf to have anything else
but me screaming at people in my [ __ ]
carpeted apartment because I live in
hell if you have a carpet you truly live
in hell you really live in Hell people
don't realize that the sign of poverty
is a carpet a disgusting dirty stranger
things era eighties carpet where you're
just like get me the [ __ ] out of here
okay it's nice to have a Persian rug
it's different
carpeting it just means you live in an
old place I live in an old apartment
building where a lot of actors and
actresses have probably said their final
farewell they said goodbye here I'm
living with their dust it's in the walls
in the air broken dreams just a litany
of failures I mean that's what I'm
saying
folks let's talk about cereal because I
am so I you know I want to talk about
cereal actually because you know when I
was a child my parents didn't do a lot
of the things I wanted they didn't get
me a dog they said my mother was
allergic they were probably lying they
didn't let me have cereal with yellow
dye number five they wouldn't let me
have Lucky Charms who wouldn't have me
all that stuff so what I did is a way to
get back at them was become a gay
cocaine addict in my immediately almost
immediately a few years after that
literally a few years after at 13 I was
doing coke and trying to find dicks to
suck and that's their fault I would have
been a married banker who attended a
golf club
if they just let me get all my fun out
with lucky [ __ ] charms instead they
said no lucky charms for you so I found
lucky charms and I blew them right up my
nose
but breakfast used to be fun right I
mean once you start watching your carbs
and sugar it gets boring it's true we're
all trying to do keto paleo whatever we
all want to survive
get the immune system strong so Corona
doesn't kill us but now you know what's
great about sleeping over somebody's
house when you were young you got their
cereal in the morning that was the best
thing about a sleepover when you were a
kid because halfway through the
sleepover usually you realized you're
like oh I hate this kid you know like
this kid's socks or these kids annoying
or these kids overly impressed with this
house and it's not that nice you know or
this kids in love with his big brother
you ever have that kid where they Nick
he's like telling you all about his big
brother you know and then you suck his
big brother off in the middle of the
night and you're like I get it now but
no the reality is the next day like my I
used to sleep on my friend Josh's house
and his mother
the next morning she'd make I mean the
worst food ever and she'd go
have you ever had such Jewish cooking
and it was like this is bad Eileen the
French toast is bad it's dry
Eileen it's dry but every now and then
you'd sleep over a real a real
white-trash kids house like when the
parents aren't even there in the morning
then you know you're gonna get the best
cereal that's when I first had cookie
krisp
or Count Chocula you know if you if
there was a cigarette full of if there
was an ashtray full of cigarettes and
and I asked the kid where his parents
were and he's like I don't know when you
just shrugged I'm like what do you got
to eat cuz I knew it was gonna be good
he plot Lucky Charms I said your parents
let you eat this he's like yeah huh so
if you want to get back to that magic of
sleeping over a kid's house whose
parents were abusing him if you want to
find that magic that you've lost getting
so excited waffle crisp if you were
eaten Lucky Charms in the morning it
means if you were a kid you were
backhanded
you got backhanded a few times by dad
when dad had had enough and my mom but
now there's magic spoon a new cereal
company that's discovered a way to
recreate your favorite childhood cereals
with zero sugar 12 grams of protein and
only three net grams of carbs in each
serving so if you're a serial freak and
some people are you can indulge an array
of classic cocoa fruity frosted and
blueberry fruity is amazing
blueberries really good too I take
they've sent these to me I've tested
them I really like the fruity one it
tastes really like pretty pebble I'm not
free pebbles it tastes like fruit loops
yes cuz they're loops magic spoon is
loops they're loops I didn't like the
texture of the pebble cereals no like
fruity pebbles cocoa pebbles the kids
that really liked the pebble cereals are
just standing over a strangled corpse
right now and they don't know what to do
I also didn't like a cluster like when
something was a cluster like like the
honey bunches of oats yeah yeah yeah I
was into that either I liked a fruit
loop a loop I like the golden gram or a
cinnamon toast crunch
I like Apple Jacks I got Apple Jacks
when the quarantine started oh yeah yeah
I got a bowl of it and then I said what
am i doing and I threw it out but Apple
Jacks is a fall cereal it's first
starting it's got a fall flavor makes
thinking Halloween's got the orange and
bright orange green loops magic spoon
spent over a year working on a vaccine
kidding that's food scientists and chefs
in the world - what's who our work okay
whatever
listen I trust them they spent it is
good cereal but they spent the best food
scientist chefs in the worlds are
apparently working on a cereal for
fatties and they did recreate the taste
and texture of classic sugary cereal it
really does you really
say hey it takes you back to being in
your white trash buddies house eatin a
big bowl of [ __ ] you know Lucky
Charms while his mother just you know
it's passed out in the room and he's
like I can't try to wake my mother up
before noon or I get hit it's keto
friendly gluten free soy free
Lokar GMO free you've got to try magic
spoon to believe it because it tastes
amazing literally guys if you were doing
keto and you like cereal and you love my
show and you want to support it this is
the way to do it listen people that have
female audiences make millions and
trillions of dollars podcasting I have
an audience mainly of men because I'm
talking sense but the problem with men
is that they don't you know I'm not
recapping the Real Housewives or
whatever else you ladies are into it's
amazing to get it's a gay it's like if
it's like all your gonna be gay and then
you have to be around a lot of women
it's like wait what I'm kidding I have a
very much respect for the ladies out
there and I love you and I want more of
you to listen and I want you to buy the
[ __ ] products okay that's what I
really want to happen I have a male
audience it's not my fault it's the way
it shook out but the women who do listen
to me are special women they are bosses
they are gangsters they run businesses
they are prostitutes they are sex slaves
they are drug addicts they give
themselves abortions they are queuing on
they're trying to steal people's
children they think we're kidnapped by
sex cults they are they have q and on
tattooed on their [ __ ] these are
special ladies they think they were
abducted and [ __ ] by George Soros the
women that connect with my material have
been to prison not Jail prison they've
done a stretch or two they've killed
their parents or their children of both
the women that
that to my show our special women
they've thought about hiring someone to
kill their husband they've thought about
it they've never done it but they've
thought about it they sit in that
suburban hell they've created for
themselves and they hear my voice they
hear it is the voice of freedom and they
think what would I have to do to just
get this stupid log out of my life and
go do something that really speaks to my
soul and to them I'm saying go to magic
spoon dot-com / Tim Dillon to grab a
variety pack and try today and be sure
to use our promo code Tim Dillon my name
TI m TI ll o n because i want to make
lots of money and i need the women to do
it because men are stupid apparently and
don't [ __ ] buy anything and just
binge free content because they think
they've all got to figured out you
haven't got to figured out your nothing
out there men
I need women I want an audience of 5000
[ __ ] they just buy my [ __ ] this show
my turn around and be straight-up cater
to the [ __ ] hoes I might come on the
show and be like I'm your hoe
that's where we're going if you start
buying magic spoon cereal I'll do the
show and [ __ ] drag and I'll talk
about whatever horseshit you want me to
talk about The Bachelor
avvocato toast cleaning out your [ __ ]
whatever you want I'm in I'll do it I
don't have to blabber about the CIA to
these broke [ __ ] all the time who cares
these retards will go in their backyard
and shoot at their tree these [ __ ]
militiamen or wherever the [ __ ] listen
you will get him out of here we'll dump
him on the side of the [ __ ] Road I
want [ __ ] that spend money Instagram
influencers basic [ __ ] that spend
it's you who this ad is for you are the
ones that need to stay attractive and
you know why because the world is unfair
and beauty androids and all of that [ __ ]
that I'll talk more about if you buy the
magic spoon cereal and if I find out
you're not buying it I will
no choice but to keep doing what I've
kind of been doing would you steer the
content to more of a male domain more of
a kind of thinking based show it's a
joke it's funny because it's not true
men are [ __ ] women are [ __ ]
everyone still forgot this isn't is this
an ad still they're gonna believe these
people I don't care it's good cereal buy
this year I'm not I'm not kidding
anymore about this I'm gonna come to
your house and I'm gonna kill your
family if you don't buy the cereal I
swear to god I'll select one of you and
random I'll come to your [ __ ] house
and I'll blow my brains out in front of
you and every day for the rest of your
life you'll see the gun going into my
fat mouth as I blow my head off in front
of you if you do not buy his [ __ ]
cereal okay
celebrity kid from Ozark whose name I
won't mention buy the [ __ ] cereal
okay you better stay thin you know you
play that white trash whatever it is
they want you to be thin you can't plump
up don't get fat it's all over for you
buy the [ __ ] cereal everybody
listening buy the cereal
Ryan Philippine if he still listen to
this [ __ ] show buy the cereal please
buy the cereal you get it you're getting
older you keep in great shape like we
get it you run it's fine buy the cereal
magic spoon comp slash Tim Dylan and God
help you if you buy this [ __ ] cereal
and you don't use the promo Tim deal if
you buy the cereal and you do not use
the promo code I swear to God I will
drive la homeless Corona patients to
your [ __ ] house and I will let them
in your backdoor and they will cough on
all of your [ __ ] while you're out magic
spoon dot-com slash Tim Dylan use the
code
Tim Dylan for free shipping and a big
thanks to magic spoon for sponsoring us
cereal I want to get the ads going
that's my point here patreon is great we
got to get the ads gone you know you
know why all the big podcast in LA don't
have patreon because they have and I'll
always do a patreon because I always
want to do content and I like the idea
of pay chunks five bucks see in four
hours is [ __ ] it's good it's real
deal [ __ ] you're not getting [ __ ] over
I've sold a lot of bad products in my
life
subprime mortgages copier machines it
didn't work and I'll do it again but the
point is that the patreon is actually a
good deal but a lot of these big
podcasts in LA they don't need that
because everybody buys the [ __ ] so just
buy this [ __ ] please I'm not gonna get
less funny I know you know what I mean
I'm not gonna go I think some of you
think I'm gonna get less funny when I
when I when I like have a home when I
can afford a house he was gonna happen
if I can't afford that I'm gonna kill
you I'm gonna kill all of you I'll find
the way to kill all of you I don't know
how I'm gonna do it I'll figure out a
[ __ ] way I'll kill every last one of
ya kill my whole audience what's ko know
this vaccine it's [ __ ] you pull
something up hear about the vaccine what
are we doing what is but what is the
vaccine here I was [ __ ] around in the
kitchen I think I got something with a
little white wine vinegar in something
I'm gonna call the CDC tomorrow see if
we started trial [ __ ] around a little
extra virgin olive oil a little white
wine vinegar I think we could kind of do
it we've we've topped over 50,000 deaths
it's a [ __ ] ugly thing man anti
vaccine anti lock down movements
converging refusing to be enslaved
here's the thing folks here's the point
it's again this is unhelpful to have
this [ __ ] I mean it's such a we have
such a [ __ ] dumb country it's such a
dumb country that it's the people are
not Governor Bo because on one side of
the anti lockdown movement you have
these retards that are like going out
there and they're acting like they have
a right to like completely destabilize
SIA T entirely by just flouting every
like common sense like you wouldn't even
have to have these lockdown movements if
hygenic take a shower peg you would even
have to have these [ __ ] locked I'm
moving if you didn't go to Applebee's
and take a [ __ ] in the booth like these
the reason that you have to be locked
inside of your houses so there's certain
people that are like I just want to go
coffin old people because that's it's
rivet and then the other side of morons
who are like who are like this
quarantine has become like a boon for
like cat mom winos who are like baking
bread and showing us their like shokudo
e platters all day and it's like enough
with that they're fetishizing this
quarantine they like being alone they
like like the idea that they can just
stare there they work at some [ __ ]
creative job they've saved up enough
money they don't understand that there's
people out there that have to really
work in America at real [ __ ] jobs okay
some people need to go out and open up
their business that they own the [ __ ]
fried chicken and grenade stand or
whatever it is cuz that's what's out
there
people need Fried Chicken and grenades
so on one side you have people be like
oh you have these [ __ ] disgusting
spring break kids which by the way let's
end that whole thing
let's end that immediately all of that
Joe what I hope truly truly what I hope
comes out of this pandemic is I don't
want to ever see anyone in public again
happy if we can go through this whole
pandemic and on the other side of it
come out with a stoic Scandinavian group
of people who like barely shows emotion
and just walks around it straight it'll
be like something good there's nothing
more repulsive than seeing people right
now here I like maniacal laughter when
you see me my friends out you'll always
see us laughing a lot but we never look
happy because we're not we're laughing
because if we weren't we would be
killing ourselves the only and it's the
type of laughter that's very unstable
and it could lead very quickly into
screaming or crying that is still okay
but genuine displays of affection and
happiness amongst groups or couples
should be over now you should be walking
around thinking about death every minute
of every day the darkness that lives
outside of you should now live in you a
little part of it
should live in you so what I mean here
is that like I understand how gross it
is if your [ __ ] cousin is in the
hospital with Cova and they're fighting
for their [ __ ] life and then you see
these idiots that just want to be on jet
skis it'll drive you [ __ ] mad but you
still have to understand that there are
people that need to go out and work at
the fried chicken and grenade stand and
I'm not saying that to [ __ ] on the
people and on the front cuz a lot of
people go but all your the leaders or
shooting on the front chicken a grenade
say number one I'm not but we deaths
what's going on in the country like and
I mean those types of jobs it's not the
rich [ __ ] don't need to go the [ __ ]
back out for the most part it's people
that work at that [ __ ] places where
they they got to be there you know it's
like the meatpacking plant which we
gotta have a change can't have the food
supply
you know interrupted by this [ __ ] it's
it's you know we need to feed the
country we need to feed the country and
I know I live in California everybody
thinks we could feed the country with
like bouillon cubes a vegetable we can't
people need to eat meat they need to eat
things that other people have killed
that large corporations of tortured put
them in up in up in a thing and then
somebody and this is why life sucks
somebody is gonna have to put the meat
in the package before you get it and I
know that's not a nice thing about irony
or mana but it's okay because listen and
then you can't tell those people not to
smoke or not to drink you gotta let them
live it up the way they want to live it
up you work at a meatpacking plant you
go you do you know don't eat organic go
to town if you're unhappy make yourself
happy yes there are better ways to do it
a long walk is probably better than a
plate of chili southwest
turn egg rolls but guess what some
people need that egg roll I saw a woman
I was driving home I'm back to the house
to do the podcast that's just a woman
like limpin she was like a decent
younger good-looking person she's like
limping down Laurel Canyon and like I
don't know what the [ __ ] happened I
don't know if a sex dungeon opened the
doors and flung around but I'm like
what's this [ __ ] going through and now
because of covin you can't pull over he
even try to help them and I wouldn't
have done it before covered but now
because of covered you can't I could see
a whole family getting lit on fire
I would just roll my window up and keep
driving because it's the right thing to
do right now because of the pandemic you
got to be a real hero now thanks bus
driver
hey thanks buster you don't take the bus
you don't give a [ __ ] about bus drivers
shut the [ __ ] up you don't care about
the people that work in a meat
processing plant you call them all
murderers you'd like their job to be
[ __ ] outlawed it was up to you
everybody would be putting edamame in
their ass and there'd be no [ __ ] meat
pet packaging plant or whatever but this
is the way these [ __ ] have to
make a living they have to do this it is
what it is it's not nice but they're not
qualified you know maybe they're not
qualified to do other things did you
ever think about that that the person
working in the meat packaging plant has
to have a job and it can't be running
Paramount Pictures maybe they're not
qualified for it maybe they're not
qualified to own a bank or to run a
business or to own a restaurant maybe
they can't be a carpenter maybe they
can't sell cars maybe they can't be a
medical assistant maybe they can't be a
physician maybe they can't be a lawyer a
doctor a cop maybe they can't work in a
diner maybe they have to work in that
meat packaging plant and that's what it
is
I would like and by the way if you work
in a meatpacking plant I'm not goin at
you I'm not even and so I'm not
insulting you at all what I'm trying to
say is that you're being patronized by
people that don't give a [ __ ] about you
because we all work in these grocery
stores and half of us this is what
really people think this is do you want
to hear the honesty of what's going on
right now
rich people want a vaccine so they can
go back to treating you like [ __ ]
that's exactly what it is they want to
get pricked so they can go right back to
walking a grocery store and [ __ ]
treating you like [ __ ] that's what they
want so this whole idea God you know the
essential workers this [ __ ] and
listen I am not abusive to workers now a
lot of people will say that's untrue
because of things that I've said before
I have never been abusive to someone at
a restaurant that did not have it coming
or that I wasn't trying to better as a
person I'm I support you which is why
this [ __ ] in Bristol farm two keeps
giving me a look he's gonna get dragged
because I want her to succeed so when
you give me an attitude when you give me
an attitude I know that you don't want
the best for you but I do so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna hit you in the
back of the head with a loaf of bread
and your mask is gonna come out and
you're gonna lick the floor and you get
again I'm gonna make you lick the floor
like you get covered like the scene from
American history acts I'm not so here's
reality let's these people should get
paid I called four and I said give him
give them cancel all the student debt
for the nurses and the doctors go treat
these essential people like government
employees for this period of time if you
work in a place like Target or whatever
and you're at risk these people should
be eligible for maybe low interest rate
low it's a portion of their student debt
- I'm all for that
I'm all for all of that but what I'm not
for is the patronizing horseshit because
I don't we don't care I don't can't no I
don't really care about you I want you
to have money and survive but I don't
care about you and you don't care about
me so let's cut it out Obama doesn't
care
Trump doesn't care Chuck Schumer doesn't
care Amy Schumer doesn't care no one
cares
true I don't you barely care about your
neighbor you barely know their name if I
see my cousin on the subway I walk to
the other car cuz I just got what am I
gonna do here oh yeah your mom's good no
it's good I said yeah so this whole
pretend
caring shed is is it's an insult to your
intelligent I don't know you woman at
this grocery store but I want you to
have health insurance and money but I'm
not gonna tell you I care I care in the
abstract about you just let it caring in
the abstract to this country you know
but they don't no one gives really I
don't care you're essential worker now
which is great and I appreciate that
because you are doing an essential
function for the moment but as soon as
that vaccine is here to kit do not kid
yourself as soon as that vaccine is here
you'll you'll go back to getting open
hand smacked in the face if the deli
counter doesn't have what these [ __ ]
want it is what it is I mean I just I'm
sure I'm making the point that I want to
make it which is not [ __ ] these people
they're working their ass off I'm
forgiving them a lot more what I'm
against is this fake thing you don't
care about can you stop can my aunt
calls me she's like they shouldn't open
the economy people are gonna die you
don't can't you don't care just stay in
your house you don't care about the red
it's and I'm not a sociopath that
doesn't have any feelings but I'm
telling you
Patrice did a bit about it was a kid
can't care there's so much [ __ ] going
wrong in the world at any given moment
your own survival depends upon you not
caring about every little thing your own
survival depends on you not caring about
every little thing you have to just get
on with it and figure out a way to
survive in this fall and [ __ ] world
and you could support policies that help
people you can support all of that [ __ ]
but don't don't [ __ ] this whole
horseshit thank you bus driver
thank you nurses thank you food delivery
please let me tell you right now let me
tell you right now everything sister
post mates bit of door - people are
sensual let me tell you right now I if I
door - if I could give the CEO of door -
[ __ ] corona if I could give him
Ebola and watch him bleed out of his
eyes hemorrhagic fever door -
the most incompetent I mean they'd best
case they deliver your food to someone
else
best case someone else eats your [ __ ]
meal and I'm gonna have to pretend that
door - is an essential [ __ ] service
they can't do anything right I'm gonna
have to say everybody working at door -
as a hero because it's two months ago it
was a stoner who couldn't sell a
screenplay and now he's a hero because
he's cuz he's dropping off meatballs
stop stop it now you're insulting people
you're making them weak and you're
destroying them and I refuse to do it I
refuse to be a party to your lies
essential worker some yes some no let's
cut it the [ __ ] out not every nurse is a
[ __ ] hero either they're not some of
them are some of them are great and I
respect the [ __ ] out of what some of
them are doing especially if I get sick
and I have to go to a hospital the one
that works on me that's one that I real
respect and I support that one but some
of these other ones I don't know that's
my whole point here my whole point is
that for our own sake and for the good
of the country and for the good of these
people for the good of the essential
workers we have to begin to abuse them
again for the good of the essential
workers we need to be to get to a point
where we can start opening our [ __ ]
and taking a [ __ ] on them because that's
when you're gonna know the country is
beginning to heal when we start treating
the the grocery store workers like
garbage again
that's when you know that this great
disgusting country of ours which is I
was gonna say almost over it's over and
then some I mean I don't know what to
tell you the hope in this country right
now is that one of those essential
workers when they're walking back to
their apartment gets
shot with a t-shirt gun on YouTube
that's their hope they get shot that
some narcissist who's got a YouTube
following decides to shoot them with a
potato gun full of money that's their
hope that's the country that we've all
created because we lie I just think just
thank you thank you essential workers
thank God that yeah bye I don't gonna
babble about I'm gonna bang apart does
it mean anything does it mean anything
folks but we've got to figure out a way
to start opening things up safely
because the country cannot become a
bunch of wino cat moms and that's what
we see who's truly fetishizing and
enjoying this to an unhealthy degree
these wino cat moms with like plaid
sweaters and they're sitting around and
they're posted photos of their goofy
pair my parents are being so goofy
they're so goofy look I made banana
bread get the [ __ ] up and get ready for
the war we're going we're having nuclear
war with China in like six months
wake the [ __ ] up I hope you like your
[ __ ] cat then we're going to have a
new what's funny is when me and Ben
started the show the idea of us sitting
in a room and where I would just scream
about nuclear war at midnight yeah
exactly what we wanted to create that
space you know but this is this is what
I mean the cat mom's can't win these
morons can't win either that are walking
around you know it's also stop giving
Candace Owens all your money stop
donating listen I know the drag stuff
can give me a little force it could get
a little annoying
you're more mad at the drag show on HBO
then you're mad at the people who didn't
give you any money the government shut
down the economy give you $1,200 Trump's
the president what are you dumb you
think Jared Goldman Sachs
Kushner gives a [ __ ] about you grow up
you dummy they want you in the street I
want you in the street and I have no
money I barely have nothing people like
Bill Gates wants to depopulate the world
I'm like so do I I just want to decide
who goes people that don't buy the magic
spoon cereal is certainly not safe
that's that great Bill Hicks Bill Hicks
did a bit like that I kind of forget it
but he was like he's like he's like
politics makes strange bedfellows he was
like people were like the Iraqis they
just want to cut off Bush his head and
play soccer with him Bill Hicks is like
he's asked what Saddam Watts think oh
yeah because that's what I want
get Saddam we're like this man strange
bedfellows you can't be overly panicked
about anything don't be overly panic
about the chip that's coming into your
neck it's probably coming but we're not
gonna be alive to see it and all these
Liberty movements that are sprouting up
around the country in spirit I I'm with
you but what are you really doing you
you know let's let's truly be honest
here is it Liberty is it true Liberty or
is it Liberty because you just want some
version of Jesus fascism because that's
what you want you just want to be a
slave to another thing that's insanely
corrupt that's the problem I have the
problem with the modern conspiracy
movement is everything goes back to
Jesus everything goes back to it's a
fight between good and evil you're just
turning your brain off you get into
conspiracies you get into alternate
alternate history whatever you want to
call it because you don't want to turn
your brain off you don't want to be
shoveled you know this this [ __ ] from
the mainstream media and the government
you don't want to take everything they
say you turn your brain on when you then
take that and it all goes back to John
3:16 and Jesus that means your brain is
off again you've turned your brain off
and you're looking for ight solutions
that make you feel good and that's what
bothers me about the modern you know the
because it's blown up it went mainstream
conspiracy wasn't ever supposed to go
mainstream most people can't handle it
they don't understand most people now
they were getting read pilled and
they're figuring [ __ ] out but they're so
they don't have any of the facts you've
never read a book they've learned about
American history through memes they
don't know anything their minds are
melting they don't understand Nuits and
they're being taken advantage of by just
charlatans to people who know that I'll
have the [ __ ] they're pushing is it real
they know the queue and I Shaddai know
the people that are making money off
this no there's not gonna be three days
of darkness which ends with the arrest
of some [ __ ] celebrity they know that
they know that they're just and the ones
that don't that's scary but most of them
know that most of them don't care
they're just figuring out a way to take
your money because they're convincing
you that for whatever reason there's
some big thing and you're in on it you
know it you're in on it and you're gonna
have a front-row seat to all the justice
it's not gonna happen how stupid do you
have to be to believe that a guy who had
the top TV show in all of Hollywood
who's friends with the Clintons who is
friends with Jeffrey Epstein who
wouldn't care if his own daughter
Tiffany was thrown out of a helicopter
how that suggested today that maybe
chlorine might make sense inside of you
to fight the vile like this guy is
leading a secret war to rid the world of
Satan he made his money with gambling
and modeling he made his money with
gamblers and [ __ ] this guy's trying to
get Satan out of the whirlwind when did
he discover Jesus he's third or fourth
marriage I mean I understand Nancy
Pelosi sucks and you want to stick it to
the Liberals but how dumb do you have to
be I want to be that donor drummer I
want to be that dumb to believe that
that guy's the guy it's gonna do it
people that would do [ __ ] like that
don't get elect a don't get have no
money the people that really care about
the children tend not to build real
estate empires with Russian mobsters who
live in their buildings who are doing
human trafficking I mean and guys at
what point do you put the fantasies down
the reason you don't want to do it is
cuz then you know it when you finally
accept that you've been taken for yo
Christopher Hitchens made a great point
about North Korea he goes you know
nobody's choking around here nobody's
talking about how bad it is he goes in
every you know fascist country you know
authoritarian theocracy he had been to
there was at least some joke or somebody
looked at somebody else like he's [ __ ]
they're really [ __ ] us here you know
but in North Korea they didn't do that
because that was the most alarming thing
about it is the lack of any of that
sentiment and he goes he asked somebody
why and they said to him they were like
listen it's easier to go along with
things than to admit your entire life
has been a lie I get it there's Goodwin
Trump's that office it probably will
take another four years because they're
running Biden but who knows P might you
know another thing I mean again the
economy is hot you know incumbents
usually win but when the economy when
there's breadlines might be tough you
know but the reality is like you have to
when he's out of office you're gonna
have to say to yourself
we got taken a little got taken for ride
by the way I don't think everything he
tried to do was wrong I think you need
an immigration I think I've been very
clear I think if he if he said what he
was gay if he ki if he if he rollback
the carried interest loophole but you
didn't because Chuck Schumer and Wall
Street got involved but if he did that
if he gets more companies back to
America if he if he focuses on an
economic policy that centers bringing
certain manufacturing jobs and certain
things back to America incentivizing
companies to come back here I have no
problem with that enforcing border
security I have no problem with that
he's done it in a cruel and inhumane and
degrading way of separating families
I've never been for
but I've always been for having a border
as most sane people are okay not to cast
of SNL but most sane human beings
understand why we need some type of
border okay okay not if you're on coke
every night and you're with other
celebrities and everyone's doing coke
and the only meals you eat is through
your nose I understand that you don't
understand why we need a border but most
people do and thank God other people are
thinking huh thank God you get paid
money to bomb all the time dressed up
like a like a [ __ ] Muppet the point
is this folks when trump's out of office
there's a lot of people that are gonna
have to come to the realization that
electoral politics doesn't work we're a
failed state and it's dysfunctional and
the only thing truly if you want real
change if you want a country that
actually function what you're going to
have to do is buy the magic spoon cereal
do you understand that you have to buy
if you buy it and you eat it you'll feel
like a child again and you'll cast aside
all the racism and all the xenophobia
and although whatever and you'll become
that child that believes again and it
was through all of us believing and
creating that reality that we can have a
new country but it will not happen mark
my [ __ ] words without the magic spoon
cereal will be will be we will be more
chaos and death to it to a degree that
even further I mean it's just gonna be
you'll see people walking around
snapping the necks of their pets in the
middle of the street or magic spoons and
don't buy a box or to buy a lot buy a
lot but that's what I'm saying I'm
saying when you grow up you know I paid
attention to politics very closely when
I was a child I was in high school and
you know a little bit of college and you
start realizing you're like oh no hidden
oh it's oh
it's pretend and people make a lot of
money pretending and I get it like I get
that people need to print like okay I
sure I understand it but what you don't
understand is that vaccine to
coronavirus is the magic spoon cereal it
is the vaccine to the pandemic if we all
eat it we'll get to a point where we can
walk back into grocery stores and start
attacking the people we can start to
choke out uber drivers again we can
start to punch the delivery people in
the face we can start treating those
essential workers the way we've all
treated them by just think about this
think about it's a year from now there's
no new cases and you've seen essential
worker and you just splash a glass of
your piss in his face that's when you
know and he says thank you because thank
you sir thank you sir and you like it
that's when you know you know this
country's back in business when just
slain Maxwell has his show on Bravo you
know she's one of the Real Housewives of
New York she's slain Maxwell she's an
international woman of mystery trying to
think what her pullquote would be a lot
of people got a lot to say about me but
they don't know the real me if they did
know the real me they wouldn't talk cuz
all [ __ ] I have them queued that's
wrong I'm just laying that's
it's pretty much what we had to go over
this week for those of you in a bad spot
don't worry about it things are gonna
get better
potentially position yourself in front
of david dobrik s--
t-shirt gun or embrace a world where no
one really cares about you
certainly not politicians and go from
there
just go from there just wake up every
day and go yep I'm all I've got no one
else truly cares maybe you find it bad
maybe you get a good friend but you
should have like three or four friends
folks stop it these these cat moms it
love the quarantine they all have a
trillion pretend friends they got a
trillion pretend friends I'm telling you
right now small group figure out what
you can do we'll all get to a point in
this country when we can piss in the
mouth of an essential worker because
that's the goal and not that's what
Trump's thinking you can't say it but
the Trump's Trump's going like when we
can like backhand a an essential worker
again oh we're gonna feel good like
everybody's like what's the thing like
what are you gonna do and you're out of
khauran tan what's the first thing
you're gonna job you're gonna go to a
restaurant and go to the page the first
thing I'm gonna do is get in a fight
with this [ __ ] of Bristol Farms get in
a screaming match with her go you knew
don't roll your eyes to gravlax and the
smokes at they're different you knew it
but she's gonna be a my my little
brothers dad from coronavirus and I'm
just gonna back him and other people in
the store gonna just give me a nod and
we're all gonna be back and we're all
gonna be dancing around and just [ __ ]
smacking smacking people throw an acid
in the faces and nurses again good over
here you stupid [ __ ] that's what I used
to say to nurses I used to go to doctors
also a nurse was gonna say get the
doctor you stupid [ __ ] now I can't
because my cat coronavirus
might have to be on a [ __ ] tube or
whatever they call it so I have to treat
them with respect but what I used to do
when the nurse walked it is I'd spit
right in the face ago take get me the
[ __ ] doctor you you oh you [ __ ] what
are you a stripper
what are your stripper you here to take
your tits out I'm a [ __ ] I don't even
want that so whoever ordered you you're
in the wrong room get the doctor clown
but I can't do that now but when we're
able to do that when we can go back to
our old behaviors look you'll get on the
bus go ride the bus on his face go your
the money way that's that's when you
know this great country this country
that I love people think Satan so
involved this country Satan would be
embarrassed by this place Satan would
run from this place very good
Saint would go here and go it's it's the
same reason that nobody no big Hollywood
person is offered to take this podcast
to make it any better
because Satan would have the same view
of this country in this world that the
Hollywood people have about this podcast
they look at it and they go well we
really don't know what else we can do
you seem to have done it all yourself
good luck